let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
number one colin kaepernick is returning
to the nfl virtually anyway ea sports
announced that kaepernick
will be in the new madden game you can
choose
him to quarterback any team you want
apparently his
his avatar uh his his character in a
game will have an 81 rating
which the kids tell me is good so that
places him like among the elite
quarterbacks in the game
which is obviously absurd he wasn't an
elite quarterback when he played five
years ago
here's the statement from ea sports that
says colin kaepernick is one of the top
free agents in football and a starting
caliber quarterback
the team at ea sports along with
millions of madden nfl fans want to see
him back in our game
knowing that our ea sports experiences
are platforms for players to create
we want to make madden nfl a place that
reflects colin's position and talent
rates him as a starting quarterback and
empowers our fans to express their hope
for the future of football
we've worked with colin to make this
possible and we're excited to bring it
all
to you today um yeah i'm sure you did
work with colin kaepernick for that i'm
sure he was he was fully on board
all in the name of social social justice
this is this is all about social justice
racial justice
um but getting colin kaepernick in the
game you know it's all
it's all in the uh when he was working
with madden
what making however much money he was
making from them to get himself in a
video game
it is all for racial and social
justice okay and money but
mainly for racial and social justice um
now of course the claim as i said the
claim to him being a starting caliber
player at the age of 32
five years removed from the game is
ludicrous
just to give you an idea kaepernick lost
his starting job
to blame gabert while he was still
playing okay
and if you aren't familiar with pro
football
suffice it to say that losing your
starting job to blaine gabbert
is one of the great humiliations that
you can possibly suffer
in an athletic context it's like it's
maybe a notch
below losing an arm wrestling
competition against your wife
okay it's it's only slightly less
humiliating than that
um in his final year in the league in
2016 he went one for ten
uh he went one in ten i should say that
was his that was actually his record
uh as a starting quarterback he won one
game played played 11.
threw 16 touchdowns in 11 games
so again this was at best i mean
generously this was a
mediocre player when he was in the
league he had one or two good years
uh and then it was sort of a
a a rapid descent from there
um he's not going to be any better now
that he's 32 and has has been doing
nothing but shooting
nike commercials for the last half a
decade but this all again proves my
point
that colin kaepernick is one of the
great
con men in american history and
i really believe that i think he's
almost at the level of maybe the kid
from
that the catch me if you can was based
on he's almost at that level
i mean if you think about it colin
kaepernick realized that he was washing
out as an nfl starter
he faced a career as a journeyman backup
quarterback you know signing
two or three or really one or two year
contracts in different
uh places around the league you know
coming in for for for training camp and
then and then maybe
signing somewhere else um and he didn't
he didn't want to do that so
it was at that moment that he launched
his fake
social justice crusade fast forward five
years
he's far richer and more famous than he
ever would have been
as a professional bench writer it's it's
a hell of a scam
it really is uh and this is why i've
never been able to generate the same
sort of
anger towards colin kaepernick that
other conservatives have
i guess because i'm a capitalist at
heart and so when i see this guy running
a con
like this and raking in millions because
of it
i can't help but have some level of
respect for it
yeah he's a scumbag and he's a liar and
a fraud but at the same time
uh this was just a massive course change
and he was able to sell himself as some
sort of social justice crusader and make
tens of millions of dollars off of it
now granted he had a lot of help from
the media and everything else so you
could say
it really wasn't that difficult but
still um
hell of a con hell of a scam that he's
running number two you may remember
speaking of scams
jessica krug the african studies
professor who was uh
who was white but claimed to be black
for many years
video has surfaced of this person back
in 2019
when she was still pretending to be
black and here she is on a columbia
university panel
seemingly justifying and defending some
gang members who hacked apart a 15 year
old kid with machetes
and she says that it's a it was a
revolutionary political act
and seems to have um a not very
disapproving attitude about it watch
how many people in this room are
familiar with um leandro guzman
feliz a 15 year old boy
who was murdered in the bronx last year
so if you're in new york you probably
heard a lot about this
and the narrative around it is that he
was an innocent kid who was mistaken for
a bad kid
right he was the kid who was hacked
apart with machetes
in front of a bodega in the bronx um and
the idea is that he was mistaken for
someone else
by trinitarios right who are dominican
gang
that comes out of rikers as most of the
radical politics of new york city has
done for many many years
but the part of the story that gets
emphasized in different ways is that he
was an explorer
right which is a program that the nypd
has to bring
youth in to eventually work for them and
so when i think about this politics of
silence that i'm talking about in the
archives right and how silence can be
a really radical presence historically i
think it's a radical presence today
when people talk about snitches get
stitches right or when we think about um
a history of anti-apartheid
struggle in south africa and necklacing
right um and that kind of
violence towards people who are
collaborating or who are working against
their communities we have to consider a
radical moment
in 2018 in which people are using
machetes to hack apart a 15 year old boy
who's working with the police now this
is not the point i suppose but my first
question is how the hell did anyone ever
take that woman
for a black person i i she's paler than
me
she sounds like a valley girl uh i mean
how did speaking of scams how did this
go on for years
couldn't everyone tell she wasn't black
just by you know
looking at her did she surround herself
with visually impaired people
did she work at a camp for the blind i i
mean i really
it's it's amazing to me that that person
passed herself off as as black all those
years
but really i guess it's not that amazing
the reason she got away with it is that
we live in a country where everyone
feels like they have to take
everyone else's self-identification
seriously no matter how
obviously absurd it is so when she went
around introducing herself as a black
woman
people were afraid to just go uh no
no no you're not uh you're you're not
that by
you're certain i don't know exactly
where you're from or what but no
no to use basic common sense is
considered an act of violence now and so
people are afraid to do that
and everybody forfeits their common
sense willingly
um you know choosing wokeness over over
common sense
we're at the point now where i could
walk into a room
and say but howdy folks great to meet
you i'm a i'm a
i'm a jamaican woman and also i'm 72
and pregnant and i can fly
and everyone would feel obligated to say
okay great nice to meet you how's
vietnam these days
that's where we are um and that's that's
that's how she
got away with it that's i guess it's a
similar thing to colin kaepernick i want
i want to
the positive side of me wants to laud
them for being great scam artists but
then i realize
the culture and the environment has made
it so incredibly easy
to run these kinds of scams number three
michelle obama is offering some marriage
advice in a recent podcast she said
quote
there were times that i wanted to push
barack out of a window
and i say that because it's like you've
got to know the feelings will be intense
but that doesn't mean you quit and these
periods can last a long time they can
last
years periods of wanting to
murder your spouse can last years
you know having murderous rage towards
your spouse for any amount of time let
alone years
i i i'm not sure that that's actually
good or healthy or normal
um i haven't been married for as long as
as the obamas have been married but you
know
we've got nine years under our belt
you know we have four kids and so we've
been around the block a few times and i
can say that i've
i've never wanted to push my wife out of
a window i can say that
which actually would make for a very
romantic valentine's card
honey i swear i will never chuck you out
a window
a little too sentimental i don't know
but i just you know i'm a romantic at
heart
number four finally tedx london has oh
no not not finally this is number four
we've got one after this tedx london has
announced that it will no longer use the
word
women and instead we'll use women with
an
x instead of an e so
whimxen wimmickson
they explain their decision here they
say why we're using wummixon
no that's not a typo whomxin is a
spelling of women that is more inclusive
and progressive
the term sheds light on the prejudice
discrimination and institutional
barriers
women have faced and explicitly includes
non-cisgender women
actually okay there's a there's a lot to
unpack here um
or maybe there's nothing to unpack this
is just a load of nothingness
this is utterly vapid meaningless
women with an x is more inclusive how
how exactly
it sheds light on prejudice how
what why when where so many questions
um though i do appreciate
this new leftist trend i guess of
injecting the letter
x into words randomly because it
demonstrates that progressivism has no
ideas of its own
no real vision no plan no goal no
coherent
thought of any kind to offer it's really
reactionary in the most literal sense of
the word
because it simply reacts to what already
exists
its whole thing is just to arbitrarily
tear down and get rid of
what already exists for no reason other
than just to do it
that's the only discernible or vaguely
discernible reason to replace women with
whimxion
it achieves nothing other than to get
rid of the word women and the only
problem with the word
women is that it's a word people have
used for a long time
and so we're going to get rid of it for
that reason uh it's the same thing with
la tinx and
and all of these or latin x i'm still
not clear on how to pronounce any of
these words
um or maybe you're not supposed to
pronounce them i don't know it's like
uh you know prince replacing his name
with a symbol is it that kind of thing
i'm not sure
number five finally for our most
important story of the day huge
controversy ignited yesterday when
kim klachek a congressional candidate
from baltimore she's the woman who made
that viral
ad about baltimore uh where she
announced her campaign she she posed
uh for her picture at jimmy's seafood
which is a maryland institution best
crab cakes
in the country in the world on the
planet without question
but the picture sparked debate because
as you could see she's eating sushi with
a fork
uh and the comments about this have been
vicious
all focused on the fork because people
say
you're supposed to use chopsticks when
eating sushi
but let me just say right now and and i
will say this publicly and i really did
appreciate this this picture from from
kim um i am also a forker
as we call ourselves maybe we should
think of a different label than that
i eat sushi with a fork i've been doing
it for years
i also have endured the scorn and
disdain for my fellow man because of it
but it is time that we forkers come out
of the shadows
and speak our truth there's nothing
wrong with i use a fork for sushi
yes i do sometimes use a fork for pizza
for hamburgers i use a fork for anything
it is a it is a it is a one of the great
inventions in the history of of mankind
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with it so
i appreciated that from kim klaichik hey
you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated